Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us for our 119th episode!
Not our 19th episode.
No, 119th episode!
119th episode!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
That was 120 episodes!
Which means it's almost our 125th episode.
It's the last FUWAMOCO Morning before a very fun weekend!
I'm sure it's been a tough week for all of you!
The last FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before a very fun weekend!
Yeah!
Hi!
It's not the last FUWAMOCO Morning, just the last one before a very fun weekend!
And so next weekend will also be a very fun weekend because it's Breaking Dimensions!
We'll also have a last one before a very fun weekend!
Hi!
For the Ruffians who are joining us maybe for the first time and thinking, what the heck is going on?
Right, you scared me!
Hi.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Yeah! Are you awake, Ruffians? Are you ready to go?
They will wake now that you said it's the last one, huh?
I always say that by accident though.
By accident?
Really?
Yeah.
Just cause you know, once we get to the Friday episode of FUWAMOCO Morning every week, I'm always very happy because you know, it's another fun week.
Another week we've had together, you know.
You know.
That's why it's the last FUWAMOCO Morning of the week.
Buh-bye!
Yeah!
Well, the last episode of the week, but
There's been another Pero Sighting!
I'm never excited for this.
There's never the last one, huh?
Okay, Ruffians.
Where did you see him this time?
Did you make sure to get rid of him?
Let's take a walk.
De-den!
He looks sort of cute.
A bit more square.
Were you digging through your concert items and found Pero amongst them, maybe?
I don't know though.
Where's Pero?
Yes!
He's not nasty.
Just sort of sweet.
Yeah.
Maybe it's all thanks to this Ruffian's handiwork.
Right!
And the Uchiwa is so cute too!
BAU BAU SHITE!
Yes!
In case you don't know Ruffians, the Uchiwa, it's common to hold them up at concerts and have something like, wink at me!
Or something on them.
Yeah.
But these ones say BAU BAU at me!
Yeah!
Super cute!
Thank you!
Moco-chan, silly.
It's your day off on the right paw.
BAU BAU!
Maybe I'm a little happy this Pero's going to be cheering for us, you know?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Huh?
BAU BAU!
That wasn't so bad.
I guess this Pero Sighting's not that nasty, huh?
Alright.
Yeah.
Nice of you.
Pero looks a little flatter than usual.
Kind of like you could sit on it.
Maybe he's been sent one of these.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
There's always something exciting going on within hololive.
And within hololive English, something very exciting is happening, something very happy is happening.
And, well, breaking dimensions.
We've all heard of breaking dimensions.
Wow!
Carly-senpai!
She just released her brand new album, FANTOMIME!
BAU BAU!
Ah, Moco-chan.
I misspelled it.
You misspelled it.
Yay!
FANTOMIME.
Oh, I misspelled.
Oops.
Phantom.
Bye bye!
But Phantom Mime, it's a full album with ten songs!
And there's actually multiple bonus tracks depending on where you listen to it, or where you get your paws on it.
Yeah, I love that!
Buy it!
And I have to buy them all.
Right, you're like, oh!
Okay, this one and that one.
They need all the songs!
Right, very smart.
And a big congrats to Calli-senpai!
A brand new album is not something that's done easily.
I feel like, really, it was just the other day that
Calli Senpai released her last EP.
I thought it was an album!
Yeah, right?
It was such a good EP!
It felt like there was so much content to it that it was a full album!
Right!
Yeah, but now she's here, she has some brand new amazing tracks.
And of course, you know, Go-Getters has been really, really hype.
Yeah, but now Go-Getters is here on the album.
There's also a bonus track with another artist.
You and I, we sing together.
I really like that one too.
Yeah, they're all amazing.
Yeah, but we were really both surprised by Skeletons and Last Days.
You know, the beginning of the album is very hype and intense.
And then near the end, it's a bit more emotional.
Bit more of a retrospective right now?
What's the word?
I don't know if it's retrospective.
Ah, in what?
Implecto?
You know when you resp- ah.
Interpersonal?
What's the word when you look in words?
Introspective!
Is that the word?
Thank you.
I'm tired to use the big words.
Yeah.
But last days especially, you know, both of them, they kind of, they're a little bit reminiscent of End of a Life.
But last days, you know, it's like a little bit, like, you know, slower.
Slower.
More like...
Relaxing in the beginning.
I don't know if that's the right word and then it heats up.
Yeah, I really like this.
Yeah!
We need to get our hands on the lyrics!
The lyrics!
I wanna know the lyrics!
But you know, I think we can all tell just by listening that Calli-senpai put so much of herself into the album.
Yeah, it's really, really beautiful.
It's so nice.
Calli-senpai of the now.
Yeah, this is that!
Calli-senpai of the now, you know, after all the experiences!
And you know, we're also so happy because we were able to call in to her stream!
Yeah!
We were able to talk to her about it as well!
Congratulations on everything!
We're so happy.
Calli's supposed to be actually doing a mini 3D live today to celebrate the release.
So please check it out!
Don't miss it, okay?
Congratulations, Calli!
Congratulations!
BAU BAU!
Cowboy Tanaka.
You're a completely different person.
Right.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Wow, there's also something else that's been, uh, kind of, uh, funny?
Kind of buggy?
Buggy?
Going on a whole life!
Yeah!
You know the other day during our off-club karaoke with you, we sung a bunch of songs.
We did a prank.
We pranked her.
Biboo, you were pranked!
You were pranked!
BAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUBAUB
And it was locusts.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
But you know it was payback for the natto grape, and... You know, Biboo was screaming a bunch, but... I think a lot of pebbles were concerned, but Biboo was not harmed in the making of this.
She was not harmed!
No Biboo's, no rocks were harmed in the making.
No!
Yeah.
And we laughed and laughed afterwards, and we had some delicious leaves and tea together.
No walks were harmed.
And actually, Ruffians!
Mane-chan had a bite of them as well!
And she was like, oh!
Actually, these are so good.
These are pretty good.
I could have this on rice.
Yeah, this would be great on rice.
Let's go.
No rocks were harmed.
Yeah.
But the candy bugs, they taste really good like candy.
Sort of like that.
They're crunchy.
Yeah.
You wouldn't think it's an elephant.
Biboo sure screamed a lot though, huh?
Yeah, they don't look great.
You know, I think that's the worst thing.
You have to get over the eyes and the legs.
Yeah.
It's a bit of a hurdle.
You should try it too someday, Ruffian!
But you know... Well... We had some after Biboo had her fill.
And we thought... I could go for some more.
So after that... We had Bugs with V-shinpai and her jabu-shinpai!
And we turned it into a potluck!
We had a sudden off-collab with both of them.
Totsu Ofukurao!
Yeah!
And Hajama and Vei-senpai, cause you know, we're all sort of there at the studio.
And we brought our locusts to Biboo's leftover breakfast.
At the top there.
Yeah, and we also brought a friend you can't quite see.
Ah, you can't quite see him.
Kind of kissing the tarantula.
But he's not edible.
No.
We brought him home.
Yeah, he was edible, but then some other bugs got him.
Now he's empty.
He's empty on the inside, they already ate him.
Yeah.
Our cicada friend!
We saw him and we waited!
We waited until no one was around!
And then I snuck him into the bag containing Nerissa's hair.
Yeah.
He's cute!
Yeah!
So we had poor Cicada, he was dead!
And then we brought him home, okay!
We had a big bug party!
He's well loved!
He is at our sink now.
Yeah.
Every time we go to the sink, we're a bit surprised!
Just because, you know, there might be other buggies.
So it's best to have it by the sink.
Yeah.
Oh, Hikoi's listening.
What?
We had a bug party all together!
And we ate the mixed bugs that Bi-senpai brought.
There was grasshoppers.
And silkworms.
And other stuff.
And a big tarantula!
A big tarantula!
Yeah.
Bi-senpai is officially the first member of hololive to kiss a tarantula.
And then, Hatsuma-senpai and I, we shared the tarantula together!
Yay!
I had some of the legs.
Along with Basen, but we shared a leg.
Yeah, but Hatsuma-senpai, we would have these together.
You're having breakfast!
We're having the tarantula taste!
Ah, it tasted!
It tasted very crunchy.
It tasted a little bit like dust.
But then when you kind of like savor the taste, it tasted like a little bit...
Not great.
A little bit like a seafood taste, but dry.
A little bit of a bitterness, but not really a bitterness.
So don't get scared by the fact that I just said bitter.
The hardest part is the dustiness.
The dustiness.
It was a very hard swallow because I didn't have anything to drink.
It's very dry.
It's like having flour that's gone bad.
Yeah.
It was like when you're trying to have medicine and you're like, oh I don't have anything to drink so you're trying to swallow that.
It was like having five medicines at once.
That's how hard it was.
Yeah.
But, more than anything, I'm happy to say maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe I'm the first member of hololive to share a tarantula with Hatsuma-senpai!
We would have these!
I know Bee-senpai has!
And Moco-chan, you had legs.
I had a leg.
Technically, it was... Wait, so many legs anyways.
Technically, it was an indirect kiss through tarantula with Hatsuma-senpai.
I'm Bae-senpai.
Yeah.
I guess Bae-senpai already kissed the tarantula.
Yeah, on the red part of the tarantula.
Yeah.
Did I have lipstick on?
Is that why?
I don't know.
It was definitely lips though.
It was fuzzy lips.
I didn't want to look close though.
No.
Yeah.
It was... It was weird.
It was fun together.
I tried Vegemite too.
Yeah, Vegemite.
It was just strong tasting.
Yeah, it tasted like miso and black licorice and a bit of factory.
Yeah.
Not a food.
BOMBA!
Good summer memories!
We're about to continue the memories!
FUWAMOCO!
We're going to be playing a very special game!
Aqua Senpai's Visual Novel Aquarium!
And Ruffians!
Plants changed a little bit.
It's an endurance game!
We're playing it to the end!
In case you didn't catch that, we are playing it until the end of the game.
You know FUWAMOCO, we love visual novels.
It's a really big dream of ours to one day release our own FUWAMOCO vision level!
So that's why we thought that, okay, we have to check out Aqua Surprise for the very first time.
And you know, we wanted to play it, but it's only up to chapter 2.
So we asked, we asked Mane-chan, can we get Brahms to play the whole game, please?
A little while back.
And!
I think the rules changed.
The rules changed!
Yeah!
And now, we can play all of Aquarium!
Yeah, it's a bit confusing though, so we will explain.
So, like before, you can only play up to Chapter 2.
Yeah.
And... But we're gonna play up to the very end, so we're gonna play up to Chapter 2 in one stream.
One stream.
And then right after, we're gonna go into another one right into the end.
Yeah.
So the first stream of Chapter 2 will always stay archived.
But then, the remaining chapters up until the end, they can be on our channel up until August 28th, and then... JST.
Unfortunately, the archive has to go private.
Yeah.
But...
We're hoping, Ruffians, that you'll join us there for Aquarium, for all of Aquarium!
The whole game!
And then, maybe if you're not able to, that you'll be able to check it out before it has to go away, so... But, at the very least, we will still have Uptown Chapter 2 even after that will be available, so...
We're really excited though, you know?
Yeah!
I've heard that, you know, of course Aqua-senpai appears.
Of course.
But Marin-senshu-senpai and Fubuki-senpai are there too, so... I don't know, I'm excited to find out what kind of world it is, what kind of things may be happening, what kind of options there are.
The tissues are needed.
Tissues are...
I'll fight for it.
When though?
Very soon!
This weekend!
On Sunday!
Please be there, Ruffians!
Yeah, very okay!
Do you have perms for your heart?
Why?
I don't know!
We'll have to ask Marnie-chan, huh?
Yeah.
Wow, a mining route is quite something.
I didn't know Senchou-senpai has a route.
It's Aqua-senpai's game.
We have to go for Aqua-senpai, right?
Yeah.
But let's enjoy it all together, okay?
BAU BAU!
Recently, we've been doing a bunch of different things.
We just finished...
We closed up Cafe FUWAMOCO, our main cafe!
You know!
You know, right now!
Holosummer.
A nice omniscient holosummer bingo!
So that's why we've been doing some funny stuff recently.
Like eating bugs!
That's not something normal for us.
That's the first time we've done that.
We just ate a lot of bugs in one day.
So let's take a look at the bingo sheet!
Our bingo sheet is OK Ruffians and we updated it together with you!
Which one was that?
That was really fast, Moco-chan.
One second, one second, one second!
Do the Ruffians agree with that?
Okay, first one.
Bento.
Bento, okay.
So!
We haven't had a bento yet.
We have to get a bento and maybe get given a bento.
Hasn't happened yet.
No bento.
No bento yet.
We can make a bento.
Play a sport!
Pro wrestling!
Pro wrestling counts as sports, right?
Yes!
Right!
Clear!
Right.
Yes.
That's a sport.
Right.
Summer test of courage.
We have...
The bugs kinda like that.
Tomorrow?
Haachama-senpai!
Tomorrow, tomorrow.
Tomorrow, tomorrow, after tomorrow.
Yes.
Maybe, but not yet!
It's still too early, right?
Yeah.
We can't mark it off until it happens.
But, once it's done, it'll be done.
Learn a new skill!
For wrestling!
We worked really hard to learn something new!
That's a skill!
We worked really hard!
It counts, right?
Wrestling's a new skill!
Yeah!
Write a poetic verse!
We haven't done that yet.
Can we write a poetic verse all together, Ruffians?
Poetic verse!
A haiku!
Haiku?
Haiku!
The rule for haiku is... Okay, three lines, five syllables in the first, seven in the second, and five in the third.
FUWAMOCO is four.
No, is that how it works?
Yeah, that's how it works!
It's five words, seven words, and five words.
No, syllables!
In English!
I'm doing it by syllables.
Can't do anything in English like that!
Really?
No!
Five words?
Five words.
That's a lot of words.
No, it's syllables!
Huh?
It's syllables in English too.
Syllables is correct.
Yeah, thank you.
I wanna write something meaningful about the summer we spent together, Ruffians.
So not bugs.
Not meaningful.
Pon-de-rings?
Okay, pon-de-rings!
Pon-de-rings.
And bugs.
No!
Uh...
A donut with you.
Okay, that's the first one.
That's five syllables.
A donut with you.
Sometimes bugs.
No!
It's for the memories.
Seven.
Write it down, Moco-chan.
Write it down.
A donut with you.
What was your line?
Sometimes bugs, but it's for the memories.
A donut.
With you.
With you is up.
One, two, a doughnut with you.
Five.
Sometimes.
Sometimes with.
Sometimes bugs.
Three?
But.
Four?
But it's.
Five.
Six memories.
That's more.
One.
Sometimes with.
Sometimes bugs.
But it's.
Four memories.
That's nine.
Ow.
Sometimes bugs!
Sometimes bugs to me!
How ya, Moco-chan?
Okay, I'm gonna erase it.
What?!
Ruffians, what about your ideas?
A donut with you.
Looking over Akihabara.
That's nice.
Looking over Akiba.
Yeah, that's seven.
Over Akiba.
We wrestle.
Wrestling.
Res-res-wrestling demon dogs.
Yeah.
Wrestling.
Demon dogs.
Yeah.
Does that work?
A donut with you.
Looking over Akihabara.
Wrestling demon dogs.
Huh?
I think that's pretty good!
Good poem!
Right?
Yeah.
Okay!
Wrestling is three syllables!
Wrestling!
Two!
Wrestling?
Wrestling, no.
No, wrestling.
Yeah.
Open!
Done!
Okay, play a retro game.
Unfortunately, Sakura Boys is a wrestling game.
A retro game.
Retro game!
Yeah.
Talk about some of the memories we did today!
That was FUWAMOCO Morning!
You know what the Popsicles conducted an experiment?
No.
Organize an event.
We organized an off-club karaoke with biboo!
That counts, right, Ruffians?
That's a lot of preparation.
Totsumachi too!
Let me have a totsumachi!
Eat something you've never tried before.
Done!
Tarantula.
Inaugural.
Vegemite.
Yeah, lots of them.
We're trying lots of things all the time.
Lots of new.
Yeah.
Okay.
Conducted investigation.
Not yet, no.
Back again, memorize all 47 perfections.
Done!
Moco-chan, do you remember where Fukuoka is?
Yes.
BAU BAU!
Next!
Oh, free space!
Your summer goals!
We have too many!
Summer is almost over!
Our last summer goal... Is to break the dimension!
Yeah!
It's gonna be done.
BAU BAU!
Watch a movie!
DONE!
We watched...
What do you want?
Princess Bride!
The memory is not good recently.
BAU BAU!
Start a picture diary.
Haven't done that yet.
We have to do one.
No bingo yet, Ruffians!
Do a leisure activity!
There must be something.
Not yet.
Soon.
Catch insects or fish!
We got our friend!
Yeah!
We caught our friend!
The cicada!
It has to be within August of August.
We went to the onsen earlier.
It has to be during the same time period.
Yeah.
Dualism activity!
That was tricky.
Hi.
Okay, cheat your parents!
Mama puppy, papa puppy!
Mama!
Later.
Have a collab!
Yes!
Done.
Many a collab.
On.
Fan service!
On!
Ruffians!
Does our 3D debut count or do we have to... pull something silly?
What does that mean?
Yeah, done!
Okay, I saw it, done!
It's done!
BAU BAU!
Done?
Yeah.
Okay!
The shima-shima sword.
Wait, we have to pour something.
Pour something.
Do it now!
I can't do anything like that now!
Maybe later, okay?
We won't make it off yet.
BAU BAU.
Sing a summery song.
We sing Sora era days, but if it was Natsu era days, then maybe, but not.
Maybe soon though?
Maybe.
Confess your sins.
Oh, is there a sin to confess?
I have nothing.
Maybe that's a sin.
What?
No sense to confess.
We'll figure it out later.
Write a letter!
Come on!
As many!
Excuse me!
Write a letter!
Done.
We wrote a thank you letter.
A thank you letter.
Yes.
You know... The 3D team.
Yeah, all the staff who... Who helped with the... I think it ended up being four pages long!
Yeah... All in Japanese by hand.
It took a while!
Yeah.
And in 3D, yes!
Yes!
Lots of letters.
And for Aqua-senpai too, yes!
Aqua-senpai too!
We're always writing letters.
That's the best way to be able to express yourself.
Other than singing.
Give a gift!
Oh!
We gave a gift to Biboo!
And to Mari-chan too!
And to the FW team too!
Find or show a treasure.
We have the treasure.
We haven't shown it.
We found it!
We found it.
We haven't shown it.
You probably want to see it, right Ruffians?
Are we allowed to show it?
We'll have to ask Mari-chan.
Bingo bingo!
Yeah!
I got a bingo!
Buffa!
Yeah, but... Can we mark off the treasure?
We have to ask.
We found it.
Okay, we can mark it off.
We found it, but we have to show it.
Okay.
Otherwise it's not that fun.
Oh yeah, Ruffians, we found the treasure.
You're not gonna see it, cause it's my treasure.
Yeah.
Look!
It's coming along, right?
It's coming along!
Pretty good?
Bye bye!
Okay.
But there's also... Huh?
There's... Inferno.
Inferno Bingo, right?
Can we take a look at the Inferno Bingo Mopa Team?
Okay!
Let's take a look.
Inferno!
Yeah!
Bingo!
Okay.
Let's take a look.
What have we done so far here?
Ah, well!
Dual waiting for a call stream with a set theme.
Daimei Cafe Totsubuchi!
Bye bye!
That was a set theme.
Send a long message of love to a hololive member.
Easy!
Not done yet.
No.
Yeah.
Create a new unit.
A new unit!
Well done!
Wow!
Akuazu FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
Oh!
Akuazu FUWAMOCO does that count?
Yes!
Yeah!
Why?
It doesn't let it.
Aqua-senpai count.
The letter, yeah.
It's a 1.
It counts!
Does it count?
Okay!
Wow, successfully... Oh!
Bingo!
Oh, that counts!
That counts!
It counts, it counts, it counts.
I don't know if it's that long though.
I don't think it was very long at all.
Was it long enough?
That was a regular level.
I feel like it was regular, it wasn't that long.
Right!
Do we want to count it as yes or no?
It was long.
Don't count it then!
Longer now!
Okay, okay, it counts.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Next!
Successfully pull off a prank.
Biboo was screaming quite a bit.
I would say that that was pretty successful.
Pretty successful, right?
Yes.
Yeah, decide for yourself.
Next one.
Eat a tarantula.
Well, there's also... I think that's pretty good for eating insects.
I'll try eating insects, I guess.
Yeah.
Well, let's mark that one clear.
We ate a bunch of insects.
It says try, it doesn't say eat!
I thought it said eat!
I thought it said eat too!
It has to be at least attempt!
You have to attempt it!
Wow!
Wait, what?
Well, try is good enough.
We thought it wasn't.
What should the free space be like for you?
Yeah, the free space.
Sing a new song!
That's a good one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Done!
Done?
Yeah, we do it with Biboo.
Oh, that's cute!
A bunch of new songs.
Done!
Okay!
Club with members I don't usually interact with.
Done!
Yeah!
Ah, that was the first time!
Bye bye!
Yeah!
But do a stream of impersonating other hololive members.
Not done yet.
It has to be the whole stream?
Haven't done that.
No.
I just met Fuwawa this whole time.
And make Italian food.
Eat bugs?
Yes!
Make Italian food?
No!
Okay!
Yeah!
Make a pizza!
A pizza?
I don't want to make a pizza.
How do you make a pizza?
Wouldn't pasta be easier?
You just, you know, put the pasta in the water.
And then you just put some oil or something on it.
Yeah.
Pasta!
We'll see.
It's all Italian food though.
I don't know.
It doesn't say make pasta.
It says make Italian food.
Pasta is Italian food.
BAU BAU!
Look at all the bingos!
Chupo bingo!
I couldn't do the Inferno!
It almost there maybe to complete all of the whole summer bingo!
Please share for us!
We'll post them on Twitter later too!
I couldn't progress.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Moco-chan!
Yeah!
Shall we see who the Doggie of the Day is today?
Not yet!
Okay, let's go to the Doggie of the Day then.
Okay!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
She looks so comfy!
Maybe that's because of Icomochi-mama's howl there!
Yeah, comfy!
Hot!
I'm so happy that she started to take a liking to us!
Yes!
Are we gonna be Maple's number one VTuber?
Hot!
Oh, she is!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Maybe we need a bit of a tummy rub that's here.
Hot?
Wee wee wee.
BAU BAU!
Hi!
That's all of Bau BAU!
BAU BAU!
Sort of like that.
Oh, it's pretty fuzzy.
That sounds pretty fuzzy to me too.
Olive!
Maple!
BAU BAU!
BAU MAPLE!
It's pretty fuzzy.
But, I think looking at this photo here,
Maybe... Maybe she's a fuwawa oshi.
BAU BAU!
Whenever Moco goes!
Good luck Moco-chan!
Am I just ignored?
Well, please protect your Ruffian lots and lots, and we'll do our best as a team of three all together, okay?
BAU BAU!
And, "Today I went on a walk".
Let's take a look!
Yeah!
We have... De-den!
Is that... the aurora?
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMA!
How do you go on a walk and spot that?
Right!
Where do you go on a walk?
Can we go along with you?
Yeah!
I wanna see the... Sugoi ne!
Sugoi!
Amazing!
Yeah, it's just a casual walk, you know.
I feel like the longer you look at it, the crazier it looks.
Right?
Like maybe Pero could just come out and fly across it.
That would be disappointing.
Although it kind of would be cool if Pero would be all in the colors.
Yeah.
Gamer Pero!
I'm glad you had an amazing walk by the end of the day.
Once in a lifetime, maybe.
Or maybe just another day.
Maybe just another day, yeah.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, did we receive a question?
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Not much longer until Breaking Dimensions.
I'm so excited to see you on stage!
Do you have special memories that stand out to you of going to idol concerts?
We have lots of memories!
But you know, instead of going to a concert of a group we're not too familiar with, but then, you know...
Being pulled all into the excitement and fun with the fans and dancing together in the performance!
Natsuru stuff is so much fun!
You never know what you're going to expect but all of a sudden you're just like... Expect?
You never know what you're going to expect.
What you're going to experience.
Yeah.
Yeah!
But then, it's just fun and you're like, okay!
I'm just in together with everybody even though I'm a newbie.
It's so much fun.
You know having that sort of bond there at the moment.
You have to be one together.
Yeah.
But we really hope that more fans at Breaking Dimensions will have a ton of fun and maybe, you know,
Decide to jump together and dance with the Ruffians.
Maybe you can meet up beforehand too!
Have fun!
Yeah!
Before FUWAMOCO will be watching to see just how excited you are before the performance from backstage, so... Please cheer for us a little bit more so we don't have to cry, okay?
Bye bye!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Please send us more doggies with your questions!
Your walks?
There's been a little less walks.
Maybe it's because it's so hot outside.
It makes sense.
But you know, maybe you go out to get something to eat.
Some ice cream.
And you see a butterfly!
Let us know!
I wanna know how your day is going!
And if you happen to see Perochi, let us know, I guess.
BAU BAU!
Well, our next stream is not exactly our next stream, but we have them!
Our Advent 3D Club is happening this weekend!
Yeah, we have it on Saturday at 8pm PT!
What are we gonna be doing?
What do you think?
What do you think, Ruffians?
Maybe being extremely silly?
Yeah.
But this will be the first time you can see all five of us together!
Together!
So please be there!
Don't forget, okay?
I feel like a lot of Ruffians may be forgotten.
Adventrix may be forgotten.
So please let them know, okay?
Yeah, and together we're gonna light the fire!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Let's take a look at our schedule too!
Actual next stream.
Oh!
Actual next stream!
Yeah!
Do not forget!
We have our Rock n' Rawr Party!
We're singing only hololive songs!
I'm so excited because there's so many songs we want to sing of ourselves but we still haven't been able to sing it.
So we're gonna try a bunch of new ones too!
I still can't believe we haven't sung Everblue yet!
Right?!
Why?
I don't know.
And we won't be singing it tomorrow.
No.
Yeah.
Or tonight...
But please join us, okay?
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I think it's just too emotional, huh?
Yeah.
It's hard.
I need to prepare.
Yeah.
Oh, and our schedule!
Yeah, we have also, we're gonna be in Seoul for POPCON!
We'll be doing our best BAU BAU-ing a bunch and meeting some Ruffians there!
And then we'll also be doing an off-club together with Haachama-senpai!
We're playing Hollow Cocoon!
And that's at 3AM PT!
It's a little bit early!
Quite a bit early!
But there will be an archive, so Ruffians, if you're maybe getting your zzz's done,
Please, please, check it out when you wake up.
Check it out when you wake up.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Muffins!
Thank you!
And for the Muffins joining us in the archive today.
Use your FUWAMOCO way.
It's BAU BAU bugs!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
It was a very big FUWAMOCO morning today, huh?
But for a very, very fun weekend!
And our 3D collab together with Advent!
BAU BAU!
But before we say bau bau for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Deva-chan!
BAU BAU!
I am Chitini!
Chuu Udon!
BAU BAU!
Kuro yuri!
Rook 397!
BAU BAU!
Hopi 800!
Rain Cat!
BAU BAU!
Sean Dillworth!
Furious Dan!
BAU BAU!
Aya.
Good of the hour!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!